hey youtubers is Charlie so marveled
will be just dropped a bomb
they spend their entire phase 3 lineup
there are a couple really big surprises
couple things we already knew some to do
a full breakdown
they actually play a little joke on
people if you remember everyone to be
talking about Captain America civil war
they actually let the event by revealing
the Captain America 3
was called serpent society and then
later to get back
ended up being civil war like civil wars
the real captain america: three movie
is that it was just a joke for people to
theater they're just having a little bit
of fun
they were outright rolling attitude they
had
basically all their biggest directors
from other peace three film sitting in
the front row there's
John Sweden Scott Derrickson who's the
Doctor Strange director
the Russos who are actually doing
Captain America 3 rumored to also be
directing Avengers 3
which is now a two-part film and Brian
Michael Bendis so
lets people denounce let's get to it
pollute any new people who despite me
for the first time I do weekly more
videos be sure to subscribe to get
everything
is New Age Voltron footage airing
tonight salt to a new video on that too
so here we go starting off is the new
movies first film after and man is gonna
be Captain America civil war debts
May 6 2016 so Robert Downey junior
confirmed for the film doing cinematic
Civil War
new notice I said cinematic civil war is
that it's not so much about secret
identities
like it is in the comic book civil war
it's about who reports to who
remember Winter Soldier was all about
secret organizations inside secret
organizations
accountable to no one the black panther
movie was confirmed Chava Bozeman will
be actor
the first time we'll see his costume is
in that movie is in captain america: 3
movie number two is Doctor Strange thats
confirm for November 4th 2016
they didn't confirm Benedict Cumberbatch
just because they're still signing his
deal
visited the only things they announced
today weird things that were carved in
stone
there a lotta rumors the Doctor Strange
is going to be a 20-16 movie
now it's just confirmed to start
shooting that around spring at next
year's they have a little bit I'm
to finalize the actor deal they will be
filming in England though
which in turn helps out because Benedict
Cumberbatch is doing a play next year
for most of the year
in filming Sherlock series for if Martin
Freeman
can film The Hobbit into Sherlock the
better to cover match
can do Marvel movie ensure like at the
same time to I know a lot of people
worried about Sherlock
but deals can be made they can figure it
out movie number three
is gonna be guardians of the galaxy to
they actually move that date it's going
to be made
fifth 2017 it used to be in June so
we're actually getting to see it sooner
which is really awesome
everyone was asking Howard the Duck in
Cosmo questions
but they said once James Gunn comes back
from vacation in Japan
no answer those questions so they
weren't answering a lot of guardians to
questions
movie number four is Thor three thats
rag iraq
confirmed for July 28 2017 Tom
Hiddleston is confirmed to be coming
back is low-key
obviously has to because he's
masquerading as Odin right now just the
idea rag rug gives you the idea what's
going on the Cinematic Universe
all hell is breaking loose literally
since they're doing rag rock
rumor villain of course Fire Lord sir
and everyone thought you might be the
four to go on
but now he's here finally so movie
number five this was actually the ones
that make people crazy
Black Panther confirmed for November 3rd
like I said Chadwick Boseman confirmed
to be playing the character he will
appear in captain america: 3 obviously
no
so he will debut in a cameo before he
gets his cell a movie
this is actually a vindication for a few
new sites because a couple people broke
the news last year that he was in talks
decision writer lecturer Bozeman I am
stoked
about their choice moving on to move in
over 60 is actually big bombshell
Avengers 3 confirmed to be a two-part
movie it's gonna be Avengers infinity
war
so everybody go crazy right now they are
doing Infinity Gauntlet
or Virginia that it is going to be
called infinity war part 1
infinity war part 2 is a confirmed cross
over movie is a crossover event guess
who its crossing over with
you have tennis so which other movie
desi also appearing in a big way
that's right basically going to be the
Guardians crossover probably the second
half to that movie though
and confirmed whether or not the
guardians will appear in both part 1 and
part 2
are just part 2 my guess is that he will
assemble the garment in part 1
and do something crazy in the spend the
second movie trying to fix it all
moving on number seven this is actually
the big WTF Captain Marvel
confirm for July 6 2018 he didn't
announce an actress but it is Carol
Danvers
it's the Carol Danvers Captain Marvel
they're not doing this marble
it will be full on Captain Marvel this
said that they would announce an actress
after they announced the writer-director
and they're still finalizing a deal so
it's going to be a little while before
we find out who's doing it
in general I'm really happy there a lot
rumors that you can get a cameo in
Avengers 2
there's the mystery woman in the trailer
that's not kill Danvers
at the Korean actress rumored to be
involved in the creation of Ultron
now the big WTF into that movie number
eight in humans
averted in a video about that so I a
link in the description if you guys will
learn more about that
that's November 2nd 2018 and then after
that movie number nine
is Avengers infinity war part 2 thats
May 3rd 2019
they basically in at nine movies between
it man
in the beginning in 2019 he did it's a
really big question they said the
originally intended to announce all
these movies the new comic on
but Alana deals just had not been
finalized yet in a can announced things
until it's set in stone a lot of people
also feel like we have Warner Bros
thank for this because they announced
all those DC movies I think there is a
little bit a true to that use the movies
are only announced two to three years in
advance
but this is all the way through 2019 is
greasy let me know that what do you
think about some these movies but he
think about Chadwick Boseman
plain black panther in who do you think
should play Captain Marvel
if you like a sack of is my number one
pick right now even just went we did a
photoshopped pic uppers Carol Danvers
I just feel like it works it's right
just in terms of other casting rumors to
I know there's a lotta been diesel black
bull rumors that have been going around
that still being finalized it's totally
possible he could do it
million going to be happening for a long
time so the prior to focus all their Vin
Diesel efforts
on guardians to on promoting that movie
just because there's so much happening
with this
I will do a follow-up to nathan is
tomorrow so just let me know what all
your questions are few questions about
civil war
and a lot of people ask questions about
spider-man and Sony in
that deal might be going on can fight he
said that wanna do not true
or two is just a rumor use very vague
about it but basically I don't think
it's happening
don't forget to agency SHIELD tonight is
going to premiere new
age Ultron footage so on try to do
another video on that automotive stuff
happening right now be sure to subscribe
to get everything
I added a bunch a link in the
description to for by Captain America
three civil war
in humans all that extra stuff in case
you haven't seen it yet you can click
here for my Benedict Cumberbatch Doctor
Strange video
in you can click here to watch the
original Tron trailer again
so good so many reasons to watch that
all day sup it's all had five of the
guys tonight